[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILLIPO MADELLA: Welcome
to Architecting Startups
with Google Cloud,
a series where
we feature the latest and
greatest startups customers
and how they are
architected and deploying
their production-ready
workloads with GCP.
My name is Fillipo
Madella, and I
lead one of the
customer engineering
teams focused on startups
here in Google Cloud.
Today I have the pleasure
to talk to Dan Schlosser,
he's the co-founder and CTO
of Ambrook, a company that
is innovating in the
agriculture space
and has a mission to couple
sustainability and profit
for farmers.
Thanks for your time today,
Dan, and welcome to the show.
DAN SCHLOSSER: Thanks
so much Fillipo.
I really appreciate
being on here and yeah,
excited to talk about
how we use Google Cloud.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Perfect.
So I would love to
start a little bit
diving into what Ambrook
does and if you can also
share a little bit the story
behind how everything started?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Sure thing.
Ambrook builds farm accounting
and spend management software.
We help farmers
manage their finances
and grow their margins to
enable them to make investments
that they need to be more
sustainable and profitable.
That's our broader
mission, making
sustainability profitable.
Yeah, the original
idea for Ambrook
was our CEO Mackenzie,
her parents both
worked at the USDA,
and so she grew up
with Ag policy conversations
at the dinner table.
And when studying climate change
at Stanford a few years back,
she learned there is a virtuous
cycle between profitability
and sustainability in many
natural resource industries
and especially agriculture.
In Ag, better soil health,
water conservation,
and climate
resilience often leads
to lower costs,
increased yields,
and price premiums for
crops or livestock.
So to reduce the upfront
cost and knowledge
barriers to implement these
practices, the things that
are holding farmers
back from becoming more
sustainable and
profitable, she realized
that there was an overlooked
part of their operation,
back-office paperwork
and finances
were really hard on farms today.
And we think we can
make this much simpler
and save farms a lot
of time and money.
So that's really where
our mission came from,
we're building easy-to-use
bookkeeping software
with tools and spending cards to
save producers time and money.
FILLIPO MADELLA: I
mean, it sounds amazing
and I love the innovation
in particular in this space.
I would love to understand
a little bit more
just to give a little bit more
context to those watching this,
what's the experience look like
for a user using a platform?
Like first of all,
how do they find you?
And then typically
is this like consumer
or a business that's going to
be looking for your platform?
And what's the experience
when they actually log in?
And what do they do,
what do they see?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
Many Ambrook customers find us
through our funding library,
which is a free resource that
we publish that is the largest
collection of farm grants, loans
cost share, easement programs
on the internet.
They can fill out
a quick survey,
share more about
their operation,
then create an account with
us to get recommendations
for which funding programs
might be a good fit.
We have provided this resource
for free for over a year now.
And we're inviting a small
number of those producers
to actually onboard to
our bookkeeping and cards
product that's in
development right now
we have a small group
of trusted testers
that are building with us.
They're our design
partners we call them.
And we onboard these farms onto
Ambrook's bookkeeping software,
we connect their bank accounts,
any finance software they use,
and their sales point of
sale system like Square,
to remove the need
for any double entry.
Once they're all
set up, they get
to use Ambrook, which means
much simpler bookkeeping.
All their transactions
from their cards or bank
accounts that they have
linked show up in Ambrook.
They can tag transactions,
not just with
the categories that they
need to file taxes or perform
annual reports but also with the
commodities or business lines
that they need to
understand their business.
They can itemize transactions,
take photos of a receipt,
and we'll actually parse
out all the details
so they don't have to
write them all down
if they went to the store and
bought 40 different things,
we can just parse that
out automatically.
And then with all of that data
captured and well-organized
in Ambrook, these producers
can see the breakdown
of what they're
spending on, be that
how much am I spending on
seed versus electricity,
versus water, versus bedding?
Or what is the profit and loss
of each of my business lines
that I operate?
So you can make decisions
for next season.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Perfect.
Thanks for sharing.
When I hear it
sounds like we're--
we could break this
architecture in several ways.
The applications but as we
were discussing previously,
it seems that you really
took like a lean approach
on how you architect
in your approach
to the infrastructure
behind this application.
So could we go a
little bit deeper now
on the architecture
side, like your decisions
around how you would build
on GCP, use Cloud in general,
and just go a
little bit, distill
what's your infra or your
stack application stack look
like today?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah, absolutely.
One of the things
that we were thinking
about most when we started
making some of our earliest
architecture decisions
was how could we
avoid a trade-off between
moving quickly and picking
the tools that were
going to last a long time
and really stand the test of
time as our product develops.
And so we leaned into
Google serverless tools
because we wanted to be
able to move really quickly
with a lean team.
We also chose TypeScript
and Next.js, as well as
React Native so that we could
build our app across web,
Android, and iOS while
sharing types and code and UI
components, not have to
write them multiple times.
We chose Google Cloud
Run and Firestore
so that we can have a
really performant experience
for our customers,
while also not feeling
like we were on a sort of set
of prototyping tools, that we,
it was sort of inevitable
to move off of.
And yeah, a year
and a half later
we're still on Cloud Run and
Firestore so, so far so good.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Perfect.
OK, I think to
help us understand
kind of the flow of
your user journey
if we were to follow
like this HTTP request
or what's the behind
the scenes components,
and how do they communicate
with each other?
If you could just walk us
through it would be great.
DAN SCHLOSSER: Sure.
Maybe we could
start at the front.
Our customers access Ambrook
through our web, Android,
and iOS apps, which are built in
TypeScript and React and React
Native.
These applications
talk to our web API,
which is built in our monolithic
Next.js web application, which
is written in TypeScript.
We deploy that web app on
Google Cloud Run using Docker,
and we have several
services configured
for production, both
static and dynamic,
as well as staging environments.
Our load balancer sits in
front to direct traffic,
deciding which request should
be passed to which services
and passing others onto our CDN,
which is also run by Google.
We spend a lot of time
optimizing for performance
here.
Next.js allows us to serve
static and dynamic content,
server-side rendered and
statically generated,
all in one application
where we get
to make a decision
for each page what
the right experience should be.
By pairing this with
Cloud Run services
that are shaped to handle these
different kinds of traffic,
we've been able to achieve great
performance across a variety
of different request patterns.
We use Firestore for
application data,
Firebase Auth for authentication
and authorization,
and Google Cloud Storage
for Blob Storage.
Not everything we do can be done
in just the 200 milliseconds
we aim to have all of our HTTP
requests return in though.
To manage asynchronous
work, from receipt parsing,
to data syncing, to
document generation,
we use Google Cloud Task queues.
We put workloads
on these queues,
either with Cloud functions
or from the app itself.
The task queues
schedule requests
to be sent back to our monolith,
which holds all the business
logic.
For example, when
a new transaction
occurs on an Ambrook card,
we'd write a new record
to Firestore.
That Firestore document creation
triggers a Cloud Function,
which in queue is
a post request back
to our monolith to
an endpoint that
will send an email
notification to all
the relevant parties based on
their notification preferences.
This lets us have all the
business logic in one place
and not have to
deal with deploying
different versions of business
logic across different services
or microservices.
Now, there's a lot that goes
into running the Ambrook
product.
Our team uses a suite of
internal tools and dashboards
and we like to
manage and monitor
our app as much as possible in
order to support our customers.
We have internal tools
built with Retool
as well as Data
Studio dashboards
that are powered by a
combination of production
databases and
database exports that
are imported into BigQuery.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Thanks, Dan.
I love the way you're
setting up your architecture.
Very simple, again
taking advantage
of our serverless capacity to
have just a quick lifecycle
of your deployment there.
Now, when I see handling
transactional finance data,
our mind almost defaults like
to a SQL type of database.
And of course, you're
using Firestore, Firebase,
which shows a lot of
the power that it has,
especially like for
startup innovating quickly.
So what was the
decision criteria like,
what was the
rationale behind going
with Firebase from the start?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah, absolutely.
The decision to go with
Firestore over a SQL database
was one, to optimize for
speed without sacrificing
user experience.
I had used the Firebase
Realtime Database
in the past, which
was phenomenal
for getting a project done
in a weekend or something
but what we wanted
was a database that
would serve every request
really quickly while also
letting us move
quickly and adapt
based on the needs of
our customers' changing.
In a startup, the only
thing that's constant
is change, so we
didn't want to be
doing SQL migrations every
week as we added new features.
Firestore has been really
amazing from a performance
perspective and it's
allowed us to do
the kinds of complex
queries that we
need to power our experience.
That decision is holed up
and we may introduce some SQL
databases in the future
but so far, Firestore
has served us well.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
Dan, this is great.
Actually, this is the purpose
of these conversations
is so we can see all the
different use cases that we
have to particular startups.
And is there any
other features that
in Firebase that you're
leveraging outside
of the whole speed on the
transaction the reason, right,
that you mentioned?
Is there anything
else that today you
think it's have been a piece
of innovation for your product?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah, absolutely.
For us, Firebase Authentication
has been extremely powerful.
It uses JWTs that allow us
to authenticate requests
both on the server-side
and client-side navigation.
It made it super easy to
set up Google, Facebook,
and password
authentication, as well
as anonymous authentication.
That anonymous auth has
been especially useful
for our free tools.
Because when we start asking
people about their operation,
we don't want to say
welcome to Ambrook,
please sign up to learn
more about funding programs.
We want to be able to say, hey,
tell us about your operation,
and then if you want,
you can create an account
to see your recommendations.
That anonymous authentication
that happens right
when they first
visit the page allows
us to ask for
information just in time
rather than putting up a
wall upfront before we get
to ask them to tell us more.
FILLIPO MADELLA: It
makes a lot of sense.
Again, once more I think
you're prioritizing the user
experience and also probably
is an audience that you want
to make sure that
you're providing
the friendliness of your
platform before anything else.
And so if we talk
about the actual,
the audience in
this industry, one
of the things for GCP
users like our customers,
is that at the end
of the day, we just
want them to thrive in whatever
industry they're choosing.
The Ag industry has evolved
over the years on the technology
side but it seems that
you're innovating quickly,
kind of outpacing usually the
industry's innovation itself.
Do you think there is like--
the way you're approaching
your technology decisions,
is it helping with this?
Or how are you innovating
so quickly on this?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah, absolutely.
I think Ambrook is a company
that really could only
be built today.
Four years ago, there
was no Plaid, no Stripe.
We're building this company
on top of fintech platforms
that allow us to
offer an amazing user
experience to a vertical
that has not really
been built for in this way
by fintech before today.
We are building on
top of these platforms
because we don't want to
be building infrastructure,
we want to be helping
our customers.
And so building
on top of Google,
building on top of Stripe,
building on top of Plaid,
has allowed us to move
incredibly quickly and ship
products that are actually
helping farmers today
rather than spending what you
might have done five years ago,
which is spend three years
building all the infrastructure
and then start to build product.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
Dan, it sounds great.
I think the innovation
speed has a lot
to do with how you're building
and the technology you
are using, of course.
So can we talk a little bit
about your deployment process,
how you're approaching
and is there any insights
that you would like to share?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah, absolutely.
We really care about being able
to deploy quickly at Ambrook.
It doesn't matter
how quickly you
write the code if
you're constantly
having to fix
breakages in production
or run tests
manually to make sure
that your latest
change isn't going
to break things for customers.
So we set up a testing
and automation suite that
runs on every pull request.
We use Google Cloud
Build and deploy
each pull request in
GitHub, using GitHub Actions
to a unique subdomain of
our Google Cloud Run staging
environment.
So each change, you can
confidently just click the link
and go see what the change would
look like if it were deployed.
We also build our React
Native application
and have a QR code where
you can pull up your phone,
scan that revision,
and any person
that's reviewing a pull
request can click a link
and see the web experience,
scan the QR code
and see the Native
experience, and also see
that all the tests are green.
So when those pull
requests are merged
we build the app, run
tests, and automatically
deploy that to Google
Cloud Run without having
to worry about any
manual deploying process.
This is something we
invested in early.
In my experience, once
you get into the heat
of building product it
can be hard to prioritize
infrastructure.
So we did that first and
it has absolutely paid off.
We deploy our web
application multiple times
per day and our Android
and iOS apps every day
and that's something
we're really proud of.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Yeah, I
know exactly what you're
saying, once you have
your first version of beta
or of production-ready
application,
you hardly find the time
or even the rationale
to go back and change
your CI/CD process
or it takes a lot of work.
So I'm glad that you are
sharing that starting that early
makes a lot of difference.
And I'm sure you faced
a lot of challenges
on the way, anything,
in particular,
you would like to
highlight so we
can share that it's
not all about roses
but we have some thorns
as well along the way?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Definitely.
We definitely hit our
share of challenges.
I would say that most
of them were around
working with Next.js,
which especially when we
were getting started was a
relatively new JavaScript
framework.
And had a fairly small community
of developers that were
deploying it to Google Cloud.
Our original application
used App Engine,
that was the first thing that
I thought of to deploy Next.js
because it was super
easy to set up.
We had it up in
like an hour but one
of Next.js' most
exciting features
is incremental static
regeneration that
allows us to statically
generate content at build time,
and then when updates
happen, have them regenerate
without having to redeploy.
The thing is if you're
regenerating static content,
you need to be able
to write it to disk,
and App Engine doesn't do that.
So we had an issue where we
were scratching our heads
and saying why isn't
this content updating.
And it actually had led to a 404
because we had moved something
from one page to
another page, and we
were like, why are
these 404s happening?
And then we realized that
it's a read-only file system.
So to fix that issue we moved
our application to Google Cloud
Run.
There was thankfully,
a pretty simple tool
to auto-generate the
config for Cloud Run
from an App Engine app, and we
were redeployed in a few hours
and we've been on that
happily ever since.
But yeah, it was a little
scary in the moment
to be like, wait
a minute, we have
to change our server
deploying platform?
Like that's going
to take forever
but it ended up being simpler
than we had originally thought.
FILLIPO MADELLA: So
looking to the future, Dan,
what are any technical
enhancements or anything
that is on your roadmap
planned for the future?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah.
Two big ones come to mind,
the first is task queues.
As I mentioned, we
use Google Cloud Tasks
for our asynchronous work.
But today we use a single queue
for all of our different kinds
of asynchronous tasks.
In the future, we
think we will probably
want to have a different
queue for each task type
so that we can tune them
for the correct sort of QPS
expectations, retry behavior,
and things like that.
We also are operating
on a single production
and then staging environment
in Google Cloud Run
but our core app doesn't
understand the difference
between these two
environments, and our database
isn't set up separately for
different environments, which
is something that we know
we're going to have to do.
That will probably involve
creating a new Google Cloud
project ID, and duplicating
all those services but yeah,
we'll be doing that
in time I think.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
This is awesome.
So thanks for sharing.
Also, we're getting to the
end of our conversation.
It's been an awesome chat.
So thank you very much
for your time, Dan.
So how do people
learn about Ambrook
if they want to reach out and
get to know a little bit more
about the company?
DAN SCHLOSSER: Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you so much for having me.
I love getting to
share the amazing work
that our engineering
team is doing.
Yeah, people that want to learn
more should definitely check
out ambrook.com/research, where
we write about our company
and the work that
we're doing internally,
as well as really
interesting original research
on the agriculture industry.
And if interested in learning
more about the company,
they can check out
ambrook.com/careers
and we're absolutely hiring.
So yeah, definitely
check that out.
Yeah, thanks so much
for having me, Fillipo.
Appreciate it.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Of course.
It was our pleasure, Dan.
We learned so much of how
Ambrook is innovating the Ag
space and providing this
unique experience for farmers
so they can focus on their
main operations, which
is to be in the field.
And also, we loved
how you're approaching
your quick development
and the way
you're approaching your
database usage and your CI/CD.
If you enjoyed this
video series please
make sure to click
and subscribe so you
can stay tuned to more
episodes of Architecting
Startups with Google Cloud.